today we're gonna have a look at a
question that involves parametric
equations but using them in a sort of
unusual way that's a bit less familiar
to what you've normally done so let's
have a look at it together
the following parametric equations each
have the same cartesian equation
you've got this fact here which
apparently applies to
one to three different parametric
equations and then you can see these
equations here they're stated in sort of
a two-dimensional vector form here with
your eye and your j unit vectors
what's going on here well we know that
you can have parametric equations that
sort of map onto a specific cartesian
equation the parameter here in this case
is t
and you know we'll often use something
like t or r or theta as obviously taken
here for the names of the equations
themselves and we're used to a
particular parametric equation sort of
map into a specific cartesian equation
but one of the important things about
parameters is that you can define
different parameters for the same
cartesian equation that's what's going
on here each of these three equations if
we were to eliminate the parameter t
we could then say well what's the
cartesian equation in terms of
x's for the i vector horizontally and
y's for the j vector which is vertically
right and that is what we're going to do
you can see here in part one it says
determine the cartesian equation so
we're going to need to do that but if
you do that for r1 r2 and r3 you'll get
the same cartesian equation
but there will be differences between
those three parametric equations even
though they all as it were sort of fit
along the same path and that's what this
question part one says explain the
difference in the domain of all three
paths and then part two so it's talking
about the direction of travel so we'll
get onto all of that
shortly but first let's just try and
wrap our head around how a single
cartesian equation can have multiple
parametric equations and the difference
that that makes the most classic example
that i can think of which we've
encountered before
within the context of well actually all
the way back in year 10 potentially is
when you think about the unit circle
okay now we have the the circle that's
centered on the origin with a radius one
and we connect it to the trigonometric
functions and this is the way that we
determine a way to
express or evaluate
angles of any magnitude in a
trigonometric function because of course
we begin with trigonometric ratios so
you're in a right angle triangle and so
the only angles you can handle are acute
angles because that's the only other
kind of angle in a right angled triangle
but then we say well what if we had
obtuse angles so more than 90 degrees or
what about when we have reflex angles
which can't even exist inside a triangle
so that's why we appeal to the unit
circle for that now hopefully it rings a
bell that when you think about the unit
circle our standard way to i guess the
technical terms to parametrize the unit
circle is to define um some particular
angle i'm going to call it a for angle
here
rather than the sometimes we see theta
as well and then you take a particular
angle and it maps you onto a specific
spot on the unit circle now let's just
think about some particular places here
because i'm going to give you a
contrasting example in a second right
if i have an angle of 0 you can see that
cos 0 is just going to be 1 and sine 0
is 0. so that's why we're here at 1
comma 0 on the um you know there on the
positive real axis right but then as the
angle increases you can see we start to
move
anti-clockwise around this circle right
so if we go all the way up to say pi on
two i mean roughly
stubby fingers sorry about that
you can see here
cos of pi on two is going to be zero you
can think about what the cos curve does
and then sine of pi on 2 is 1 and so
that's why you're up here well you know
i i tried to get as close as i could i
want to get to about
1.57 but i don't think my fingers are
going to do it anyway you get the idea
i'm pretty close there okay now
obviously as you then keep on going all
the way from naught to two pi it gives
you all of the different points on the
unit circle and it just goes round and
round and round as you're familiar with
okay
and the important thing i want you to
notice as you're seeing this is if we go
right back to the first quadrant here
right
when you start off at zero um as you uh
increase the angle what's happening to
cos and the answer is it's decreasing
right think about the cos curve starts
up at one and it just drops down towards
the um the x-axis right what that
corresponds to here is your x-coordinate
is decreasing right it decreases all the
way from naught over to pi right because
if you think about the cos curve from
naught down to pi
or across to pi i should say the cos
curve is decreasing so your x coordinate
in this space is decreasing
what about the y coordinate well when
you think about the angle increasing
from 0 to pi
when you think about the sine curve it
starts at zero it goes up and then it
goes down and that's exactly what the y
coordinate does here on the unit circle
as i move from naught to pi you can see
here's my y coordinate imagine it going
up and then once you hit pi on two it
starts to come back down again just like
the sine curve does okay
now like i said this is the standard
parametric equations
for the unit circle x equals cos of your
angle and y equals sine of your angle
but this is obviously not the only way
to think about the unit circle
parametrically if i just take off that
coordinate there and if i think about an
alternate way of measuring this let's
actually put us back at zero
spoilers slightly uh what's going on
here right well what i've done is i've
defined the uh the coordinates on the um
the coordinates rather on the unit
circle's circumference as rather than
cos theta or cos a sine a i've just
reversed my cos and my sine so you can
see i'm making sine the x coordinate and
cause the y coordinate now what's going
on here well a couple of things for
starters when my angle is zero i'm not
starting on the positive real axis here
i'm starting on the positive um
positive real axis you know the complex
plane i'm not starting on the positive
x-axis i'm starting on the positive
y-axis why is that part of the pun well
when you take sine of zero
sine of zero now corresponds to the
x-coordinate and sine of zero is zero so
that's why you can see i'm along x
equals zero i'm on the y axis right and
correspondingly cos a
when you have cos zero that's going to
be one so that's why vertically now i'm
up at one
what happens now when i start to
increase the angle before i do it maybe
you saw it before i did it very quickly
before i do i wonder if you can picture
what's going on here right
we noticed that sine it starts
at 0 and then it goes up and then it
comes down right that used to correspond
to our vertical but now it's going to be
our horizontal right so it's going to
start at zero you can see i'm at x
equals zero at the moment but it's going
to increase to begin with until pi on
two and then it will decrease
think about what that's going to mean
horizontally horizontally to increase
from zero and then decrease in
horizontal terms and then think about
what's going to happen for cos right
when you start from zero cos of zero is
at one and you as you increase you know
cos 0 cos pi on 6 cosine 4 cos pi on 3
cos pi on 2 all the way you're
decreasing that's what the cos curve is
doing all the way to pi so think about
what that means vertically you're going
to be decreasing all the way from naught
to pi all right are you ready i'm going
to press play on the parameter a now and
what's what's going to happen this green
point we'll just watch it right
do you see what's happening
i'm moving clockwise which is the
opposite direction to how i was moving
before and i wonder if you can see
why that is right from naught to pi my
horizontal coordinate it's increasing
all the way up to pi on two and then it
starts decreasing again once you hit pi
because that's what sine does it starts
with zero it goes up and then it goes
down a better way of saying that is it
increases then it decreases but now sine
is the horizontal coordinate so
horizontally increasing corresponds to
moving to
the right and then horizontally
decreasing corresponds to moving to the
left you can see i'm now moving back
toward the x-axis in exactly the same
way
the cos
coordinate which is the y-coordinate now
it steadily decreases or maybe steadily
is not exactly the right word it sort of
changes in gradient but it decreases all
the way from naught to pi and that
corresponds to vertically decreasing
from one all the way down to negative
one which is exactly what the cos curve
does
and that's why you can see when i hit
play right
i start at a different spot namely up on
the positive y axis and i go in a
different direction so you can see here
how the x equals sine a y equals cos a
set of parametric equations gives me the
same unit circle but it helps me move
around the unit circle in a different
way i've got a different starting
location and i've also got um a
different direction to move in okay